unfortunately I'm married to someone
that has eaten the same thing for the
last 25 years since since I've met
Victoria she she only eats you know
grilled fish steamed vegetables she'll
very rarely deviate away from there the
only time that she's ever probably
shared something that's been on my plate
was actually when she was pregnant with
Harper do you remember and it was the
most amazing thing it was it was my one
of my favorite evenings I can't remember
what it was but I know that she's not
eating it since
oh Lord
give me strength today I'm attempting to
eat like Victoria Beckham
[Music]
all right so where do I even attempt to
begin so about a year ago I did a video
unpacking Victoria Beckham's very
extreme diet and that's not even just
like my interpretation like those are
pretty much her words as she once told
Huffington Post that I'm quite extreme
in anything I do whether it's eating or
working out or drinking or not drinking
um yikes so today I'm going to be using
Victoria Beckham's alleged diet As Told
by some primary and some secondary
sources and I'm gonna be building it out
Abby style to turn them into hunger
crushing combos that are satiating and
satisfying and that I like actually want
to eat a reminder that this is just what
I ate today on a random day it's not
meant to be duplicated not my diet and
also not Victoria's original diet I
refuse to even follow Victoria's alleged
diet to a tea because that would not
satisfy my own unique needs also I will
be discussing restrictive eating
patterns so please feel free to skip
this video if it's not supportive to
your journey but if you are not already
subscribed here hit that subscribe
button and follow me on Tick Tock and
Instagram at Abby's kitchen alright
let's get into it okay so according to
Hello magazine Victoria avoids tea and
coffee in the morning and instead has
two tablespoons of apple cider vinegar
on an empty stomach followed by some
warm lemon water of course she does Abby
can you please just like quickly go over
this again trust me I am over it too so
I don't really know Victoria's rationale
for the vinegar but there are a lot of
influencers citing a number of alleged
benefits that we really should unpack
number one is that it causes weight loss
one small study found that consuming
vinegar with a meal increase satiety and
cause participants to eat about 250 eat
less calories in a day but other
research suggest that the main reason
for this is simply that it makes you
feel so nauseous that you don't want to
eat that much at the end of the day it's
really unlikely to make any kind of
significant impact on weight without a
calorie deficit number two is for blood
sugar management now vinegar does seem
to have a blood glucose lowering effect
possibly because it's thought to delay
gastric emptying so it may be beneficial
for folks with insulin resistance PCOS
or diabetes and third is that it can
help to reduce bloating so this one is
really dependent on the cause of
bloating if you legitimately have low
stomach acid which is estimated in about
20 percent of Americans then
theoretically drinking some acid might
help but otherwise if not we have
evidence that it may delay gastric
emptying like I mentioned so it could
potentially even worsen up bloating in a
lot of folks drinking vinegar is also
not without its risks dentists
consistently warn patients about the
damage to tooth enamel and also about
the worsening of existing gastritis so
yeah I have like the most sensitive
teeth of life that would literally ruin
my day you know what else would probably
ruin my day not having coffee so not
surprisingly I'm gonna have my coffee
and some regular water
all right so for breakfast Victoria
apparently either has her green monster
smoothie or avocado toast on Ezekiel
bread both super nutritious options it
says the Smoothie apparently has apples
kiwi lemon spinach broccoli chia seeds
and coconut water so we're getting some
Fiber we're getting some healthy fats
and maybe a little bit of protein in
there as well and the avocado Toast of
course has fiber or healthy fats and
also a little bit of protein thanks to
the choice of bread Ezekiel bread is
considered one of the more nutrient
dense options on the market right now
thanks to its use of spreaded grains
sprouting reduces the greens
anti-nutrients and gluten while
increasing vitamin synthesis which also
improves nutrient availability and
digestion one slice has four grams of
protein three grams of fiber 15 grams of
carbs and no added sugar or
preservatives so it does make sense that
the clean eating Queen chooses this
brand so I really like Ezekiel bread but
like one slice would definitely not be
enough for me I couldn't even find the
same brand as hers this one is more
substantial size per piece and yeah I
mean definitely need two I also feel
like I'd want the smoothie and the toast
and even with both those things I might
want to bump up the protein a little bit
as well so let me show you what I'm
going to do this is what we call a
Kinder Apple the kids take one bite and
then leave it to rot so we're gonna use
that in our smoothie today
I do not know her ratios I'm just going
to add what I had in the house spinach
some steamed broccoli
uh
chia
okay
I'm gonna add some hemp Hertz for some
extra protein
and she uses coconut water so
guess we're trying that
all right
let's give her a go
[Music]
not sure if I'm
excited about this let's just try a
little a little something first
a little chunky it's a little farty I
feel like it needs some banana or
something sweet
let's do that we're going to try to
salvage this because you guys know I
hate wasting food but
this
might get wasted
plus I feel like it definitely needs
some more carbs
two bananas will do
I just had to give one last fart in my
face to just release the Aromas
it does look like Shrek Shrek's poop
looks like a like a Halloween recipe
that you would make for your kids just
like you know because you found it on
Pinterest but no one actually eats it
you know what's much better the chia
seeds are a little aggressive in the
texture but I will say the banana she
turned this around avocado toast I can
do so we're just gonna kick this off as
usual avocado I hate when they cheat you
like that also I am unsure if I'm
allergic to chia seeds but I'm I'm
experiencing a lot of tingling in my
mouth can somebody tell me if that's
normal or not because I have not I don't
think I usually feel this when I have
Gia
my spider sense is tingling I'm being
watched weird
um okay so let's just get that in there
this is our healthy fats plus our fiber
my little hack is I'm going to add in
some cottage cheese if you haven't
figured it out by now folks I love
cottage cheese I put it in a lot of
things because it's such an easy source
of protein and it's got a very neutral
flavor
yes you can puree this and make it more
beautiful but I already dirtied up my
blender I'm not dirtying up a whole
other Appliance nobody's got time for
that not Victoria Beckham not me
Beauty just add a little bit of lemon
for some flavor
nice all right
smear that bad boy down
got some Tomatoes a little feta on mine
for some saltiness
and because I already have my hemp
hearts out obviously
a little sprinkle
oh say that's a big upgrade from a
single slice of toast or a [ __ ] nasty
fart smoothie
all right let's do a little recap we got
fiber in our fruit our bread Plus in our
avocado lots of healthy fats in the hemp
hearts in the avocado and the chia seeds
plus some protein in the cottage cheese
the Chia and the hemp I'm excited to dig
in
um
sugar okay so according to Victoria's
interview at the times she apparently
works out at least twice a day every day
for at least two hours a day I read that
she does like an hour of running
followed by an hour of strength training
but your girl doesn't run because
hashtag motherhood hashtag prolapse
hashtag I cannot run without peeing my
pants nor do I have two hours to work
out today so yeah I'm gonna do like a
like a quick little walk on an incline
and maybe like a full body workout and
call it a day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's talk lunch so according
to multiple sources including her own
husband Victoria's diet basically
consists mainly of vegetables fish and a
ton of avocados and nuts in 2019 she
told the telegraph that she consumes
three to four avocados a day to keep her
skin glowing that's a lot of avocados
hey the woman is a goddess so I get the
temptation to want to eat four avocados
in a day if Posh says that's what makes
her glow and it is true that avocados
are rich in antioxidants like vitamin c
and e which has been shown to play an
important role in preventing skin damage
along with monounsaturated fats to
improve skin elasticity but eating
literally half of your total caloric
needs for the day in avocados displaces
a lot of other important foods and
nutrients like protein for example hence
why both of her breakfast options were
pretty low in protein as is I like
avocados but I would never want to eat
like four of them in a day so we're
gonna compromise here I'll add a bit of
avocado to my salad but I'm also going
to amp this up like tenfold because yeah
one shouldn't have to live off
vegetables and fish alone let's make a
balanced salad saposh usually just eats
straight up veg but I need some carb
action going on so I've got some
pre-cooked Israeli couscous here that
I've toasted and batch prepped throw
some of that in we got our greens which
I know she's a fan of
these ones we actually grew I had some
beautiful purple cabbage we'll throw
that in there as well for some color I
feel like an apple always goes well in a
nice fall salad we obviously just went
apple picking like every other basic
[ __ ] in Canada so we got a ton of
apples to go through so they gotta go in
everything we eat
I love raw fennel it's got a really nice
licoricey flavor and like an amazing
crunch
I think it's one of the most underrated
vegetables in the vegetable Kingdom
all right our nod to our avocado Queen
she apparently likes nuts too so we're
gonna throw some pistachios into the mix
I don't think she eats cheese but I do
and I like a lot of cheese so I need
some cheese on my salad a little feta
action
and I've cooked some salmon here so of
course that can go down
delish and we need some dressing now
according to Victoria I'm a very fussy
eater I like things to be cooked in a
very simple way I don't like oils and
Butters and sauces but you guys are
always so accommodating and always cook
the food exactly how I like it very
simple very clean incredibly fresh and
just perfect and then you know I love
some steamed vegetables on the side some
balsamic vinegar and then to season
myself
why are you filming this
don't throw my struggles
oh man how am I gonna get that lid back
on
all right
new making dressing was so complicated
all right
so yeah
I don't need to be taken back to like my
anti-oil days or my eating disorder
because my sensitive teeth cannot just
handle drinking straight up vinegar on
my greens so we're going to make a
simple vinaigrette a little olive oil a
little balsamic well this is good stuff
too
mm-hmm I'm not measuring
some mustard
salt and peppers
let's do a recap we got carbs in our
Israeli couscous plus of course our
fruit in here lots of fiber in the
avocado the fruit the greens all the veg
tons of protein and healthy fats in our
salmon more healthy fats in our nuts our
olive oil and our avocado I don't know
about you but this is a huge upgrade
from just steamed vegetables and fish
this is going to be the most unposh
salad bite you'll ever see
foreign
let's talk dinner so again David's being
quoted as saying since I've met her
she's only eaten grilled fish steamed
vegetables rarely deviating away from
there listen I love fish I think it's a
great nutritious source of protein and
healthy fats if we're talking about fish
like salmon but at the end of the day
variety is the spice of life wasn't that
like lesson number one in Spice Girls
School
but aside from just like straight up
boredom there are a lot of potential
risks of consuming an excessive amount
of the exact same foods every single day
not only does eating basically only fish
as a source of protein Edge out other
nutrient dense foods with a variety of
health benefits but it also puts one at
a higher risk of mercury poisoning once
that he found that folks with the
highest intakes of fish including salmon
and tuna were more likely to have high
mercury levels in their blood so how
much is too much well my colleague Eric
Williamson and I had to do some serious
number crunching But ultimately it does
depend on the type of fish they are
eating the reference dose for safe
intake is 0.1 micrograms per kilogram of
body weight per day so for someone
around Victoria's size that's around 38
micrograms per week if we take a very
conservative estimate at the high end of
all of the low-risk seafood options
that's about 2.2 small three ounce
servings of fish per week and if we were
to choose salmon which is one of the
lowest Mercury options that still is a
maximum of 10 small servings of salmon
per week so if we're consuming fish
twice a day because it's our only
protein Source you can see that we would
be well over the safe amount every week
and mercury poison is no joke causing
anxiety depression numbness Tremors
memory problems and potentially even
more devastating effects so yeah I'm
going to switch things up entirely I'm
not going to do fish for good reason I'm
gonna do chicken I'm gonna stir fry some
veg I'm gonna add some spices because I
like my food flavored with things other
than just straight up vinegar and we're
gonna do a simple little taco night
let's do it a little bit of olive oil
I've got onion
and bell pepper
a nice melange of colors I got some taco
seasoning do I think that Posh Spice
would consume this no but I'm a mama too
I don't have time to make taco seasoning
from scratch okay I'm like the real
Spice Girl because I use actual spices
even if I get them out of a packet
all right I'm gonna add in some basic
chopped up rotisserie chicken some black
beans a good pasta Rooney maybe a little
more seasoning
am I supposed to do I'm supposed to add
water I never did that
all right let's build some tacos
[Music]
let's do a recap we got fiber rich carbs
in our tortillas plus lots of veg we've
got more healthy fats and fiber in the
avocado plus lots of protein in our
black beans and our chicken it's not
fish and steamed vegetables but I'm
really happy about that
hmm
all right so what can we take away from
Victoria's Day of eating well I'd say
with my little tweaks in there it
actually turned out pretty okay
obviously had I followed Victoria's diet
to a tea I would be in meltdown City
right now like balls deep in a
family-sized bag of chips and speaking
of chips I think I want some chips but
instead I'm just gonna have a portion
that I feel will satisfy me
now you know I think it's important to
share that whenever Victoria is
interviewed about her diet she ends up
saying something like this and the way
that I I'm I'm very very disciplined I
work out a lot and I eat very very
healthily that's just who I am and
that's just you know I'm not the most
exciting eater and of course the media
is always so quick to compliment and
praise her for her commitment to health
but conflating being healthy with your
identity is really the backbone of
Eating Disorders like orthorexia so I'm
really not okay with making healthiness
some kind of flex of course we all want
to be healthy and engaging in health
promoting behaviors is obviously very
important but not when it becomes the
Crux of who you are because yeah I was
that girl and I was very very sick so I
really think we need to stop glamorizing
that kind of life and on that note
that's all that I have for you guys
today if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up leave me a comment
below on who or what you'd like see me
review or try out next subscribe to the
channel and I'll see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]